Keegan I've taken the liberty of speed
into some of the first stars and I just
want to read you some of the adjectives
they use to describe your approach okay
thrilling
disturbing um
super freaking weird three yeah three
things that I was going for yeah yeah
especially the last one there's a lot of
conjecture about like did did you lose
yourself in the role did you go crazy
did you lose your mind yeah right what
do you say to those folks out there
absolutely yeah yeah I was gone I didn't
know where I left off and where toad
began I'm a tall slender
African-American man he's a short fungus
someone that can cause somebody anywhere
from uh you know a mild stomach ache to
death serious stuff yeah I've been told
I can do the same well you know sure how
does this change you going forward
well I now know that I can play
vegetables